guys i have been really excited to make
this video
[Music]
the batman might just be my favorite
batman movie of all time now for those
of you out there that want to avoid
spoilers don't worry i'll give you a
heads up when we head into spoiler
territory so these are just my spoiler
free thoughts to kick things off the
past few weeks have been an intense
albeit fascinating journey into a
franchise i once knew very little about
i have watched through 12 batman movies
and read a countless number of comics
leading up to this brand new outing and
i am so pleased to say it was worthwhile
not just because it's opened my eyes to
the brilliance of such an iconic
character batman but also because it's
allowed me to appreciate these movie
adaptations on a whole nother level and
that couldn't be truer than with this
film
the batman
this movie feels like a test of my
ability to point out what comic is being
adapted at any given moment and given
how much i freaked out at being able to
do just a little bit of that with batman
begins it should come as no surprise to
you all that i had a lot of fun with
this one this is
unquestionably the most comic accurate a
batman movie has ever been both in terms
of its tone and its design gotham city
is the bleakest it has ever looked
filled with fantastic gothic
architecture against a backdrop of grimy
urban areas like the most run down
sections of new york city it is smoky
filthy and right off the panels of many
of the comics i've been reading
currently stunningly shocked by the
wonderful greg frazier whose work has
already blown me away on june and rogue
one and you have the best looking batman
film to date and with this deeply newer
setting comes a deeply newer story in
many ways the batman doesn't feel like a
traditional superhero flick and having
watched 12 movies in preparation for
this it was a welcome change of pace
across its three-hour run time there's
not a whole lot of action this is a slow
burn detective thriller in the same vein
as david fincher's seven or more
directly it's a murder mystery taking
heavy cues from the long halloween and
dark victory comics with some subtle
nods to even batman hush it shows batman
the world's greatest detective actually
doing detective things as the primary
driving force of the film coupled with
batman's introspective narrative that
underpins so many moments across this
film and you have such a phenomenally
faithful incarnation of this character
and so i think regardless of whether you
like this take the best or not it is
unquestionably right off of the pages
and personally i can't praise it enough
for that thankfully it is also a great
film in its own right and not just a
series of references in a row to appease
fans the cat and mouse game between the
riddler and batman is incredibly
compelling and thematically competent
and the way matt reeves and the rest of
the writing team have constructed a
young misguided bruce wayne is an
absolute joy to watch topped off by such
an oppressive score by michael giaccino
and you have yourself one hell of a
batman movie it's my feeling that this
is a movie that will appeal to fans old
and new while also being approachable
for ones who might not necessarily love
superhero films so if you or your family
haven't seen it it's a thrilling ride
the likes of which i don't believe you
will soon forget now spoiler one if you
do not wish to be spoiled then i think
this is time for you to leave and come
back once you've seen the film i will be
touching on almost every major plot
point in this film seriously like
everything and there's a lot to cover so
let's get right into it
the central conflict the plot of this
film is made up of several major factors
at the forefront of the story you have
the riddler who's taking out gotham's
corrupt elite via some truly twisted
methods throwing out riddles that batman
must solve in time intertwined in this
is the story of carmine falcone the
penguin and their involvement in gotham
city's corrupt police force if the
premise of a killer on the loose taking
down mob assets sounds familiar to you
then you'd be correct for all intents
and purposes this is the exact plot of
the long halloween comic and considering
they were literally handing out issues
of number one at the cinema
they're not shy about sharing that
inspiration this time however there is
no holiday killer but instead we have
paul danos riddler who despite not
having much screen time at all gives one
hell of a powerful performance the
incarnation of the character here is
startlingly different from much of his
comic book appearances in terms of tone
in catwoman when in rome he's kind of a
dorky loser and even in comics more
central to him like those found in new
52 or rebirth he's still a bit too campy
and extravagant for a live action movie
such as this and as a result what reeves
has done with this character is quite
the departure and yet also not the
riddler in this movie is presented much
like jigsaw from the saw series he puts
them in awful situations and leaves
riddles that may allow some of them to
be saved yet at the same time his
reasoning is 100 in line with what's
found in the comics he's beaten down by
society he feels unnoticed and bitter
and his sense of self-worth about his
own intelligence and desire to be
noticed grows to psychotic degrees which
was exactly what i found when reading
the four of a kind comic for my batman
forever review however it has been given
a more grounded modern twist riddler's
revealed to have a small online
following only 500 people of which he
manages to radicalize only a few for his
deeds and yet that's just enough to do
significant damage it's not hard to see
the analog here to real-life cases like
elliot roger a deeply disturbed young
killer who found himself glorified by
similarly messed up people who
felt slighted by society batman and by
extension bruce serves as a parallel to
this take this is only year two of his
career and he hasn't quite worked out
what the batman needs to be or even how
to really function as bruce wayne
there's no suave ladies man on show here
this is a very young tortured individual
who repeatedly calls himself vengeance
he feels let down by what the city has
become what's happened to his people and
wants revenge on those who made it this
way
exactly
like our villain the riddler
thematically this is so important and
one of the coolest parts about this
movie one of the major turning points is
a section towards the end where the
riddlers in custody and batman rushes
over believing his identity has been
sussed out due to the countless bruce
wayne indications all throughout his
apartment only it turns out that wasn't
the case in a brilliant bit of
misdirection it's revealed that the
riddler wanted to team up with batman to
take down bruce wayne
someone he saw as the embodiment of
corruption that deeply affected his
childhood as an orphan another clear
parallel by the way this interrogation
scene is spectacular it's revealed that
riddler saw batman as an ally his warp
sense of reality led him to believe that
they were working together all of this
time to clean up gotham's corruption the
riddles weren't meant to be there for
batman to stop the next death they were
there for him to solve thus moving
pieces into place to allow for his next
plan to play out successfully and so now
that you have batman someone riddler saw
as a kindred spirit telling him he's a
maniac psychotic and wrong on every
account he's left with this worldview
completely shattered and dano's acting
here just blew me away he is completely
unrestrained all of the composure
intelligence that marked his performance
up until this point seeps away and
what's left is a pathetic lunatic quite
literally screeching it's the moment
where ridler's quote-unquote mask drops
off and we finally get to see the
sniveling loser we know and love from
the comics it's such a fascinating
portrayal of this character most
critically though it's a powerful moment
of resilience for both characters
particularly batman who begins to come
to terms with how wrong his notions of
vengeance truly are in an earlier
section of this film bruce meets a man
who is beyond done with gotham's
societal failings and this seemingly
one-off character poetically wraps back
around to become one of riddler's
radicalized thugs who upon being
recognized by batman states i'm
vengeance finally making a click that
batman needs to be a symbol of hope and
not one that inspires misguided copycats
seeking revenge it plays off a common
idea that batman may very well be a
large part of creating many of the
villains he so desperately tries to take
off the streets it's a fitting part of
this early story for the batman
character and i absolutely love the way
it was handled it's what this film story
hinges on and they not only pulled this
narrative trick off but they set the
standard in my opinion this is
everything this film needed to be and
more
okay now time to talk about the inner
workings unsurprisingly across this
three-hour run time there's a lot more
at play than just the core concepts i've
outlined so far one of the other central
stories that underpins riddler's plans
is about the mob and their involvement
with not only gotham's police but its
political structure too at the center of
this story is carmine falcone selena
kyle the penguin and bruce wayne not
batman but wayne himself it's here that
the film's numerous comic influences
come out in full force and it even
included a comic reference that aj never
expected to be relevant and so never
told me to read beforehand and that
comic is 2012's batman earth 1 and it
takes elements from it that really
caught me off guard as someone who only
familiarized himself with the more
conventional batman stories in this film
alfred's not the old butler i'm used to
he's younger and much tougher with a
military background portrayed
wonderfully by andy serkis but most
critically what it takes from earth 1 is
the plot point that martha wayne why did
you say that
spend time at arkham and her mother
suffered a mental breakdown killing her
husband and then herself it merges this
with a plot point from the long
halloween where thomas wayne saves
falcone's life and owes him a favor as a
result it creates this plot point where
bruce believes his father to be corrupt
working with falcone to have a reporter
killed who was going to spill the beans
on martha's dark past an act that would
ultimately cause martha and thomas's
device and with a film like this which
is built upon shattering preconceived
notions of the world
it's a perfect source to draw from with
the riddler revealing this to the city
it completely devastates bruce who was
entirely under the impression his
parents were saints he loses faith in
himself and his reasons for what he's
doing and he also loses faith in alfred
believing he's been lied to his whole
life it results in one of the most
touching scenes in the film where
circles and pattinson
really get to flex their acting chops as
they reconcile and alfred explains the
reality of this situation bruce's father
never meant to have anyone killed in a
moment of weakness he turned to falcone
to try and scare the reporter only for
falcone to go all the way he explains
that thomas wanted to go hand himself in
and tell the police everything only to
end up dead possibly at the hands of
falcone possibly by pure coincidence by
a desperate criminal it's left
unanswered something also present in the
long halloween it's a different take
from the tale of joe chill the man
responsible for their deaths in the
nolan movies and a huge number of batman
comics dating back all the way to the
original series in the 40s to have this
big unknown cast a shadow over the
motivator behind the batman is hugely
relevant here and ties into the
conclusion of this movie that batman
should not be a symbol of vengeance are
you seeing how everything is tying
together yet and i think that's what
makes this movie so different from all
the other adaptations over the years so
many of the live-action batman movies
are focused on the villains but this
movie is so so much more focused and
grounded around the character of batman
that it's hard to find ways to touch on
anyone else succinctly selena kyle plays
a prominent role here for example taking
on the look of her character from batman
year one but with a backstory straight
out of dark victory and the new 52 with
carmine falcone being her actual father
he even gets his iconic face scratches
too which i thought was pretty dope i
think what she does best for the
narrative though is the way she
indirectly confronts bruce wayne about
his background she pushes batman on his
reactions to certain situations saying
it's clear he grew up rich and it's an
aspect of the character that seldom
touched on how does someone who grew up
so deeply privileged even begin to
understand the people driven to crime
out of reasons like desperation she
facilitates the way this film makes
batman feel human and this is such an
early take on the character he routinely
messes up he can't just tank bullets and
he often relies on the help of others to
set him straight outside of selena the
most prominent person to provide said
help is james gordon in many ways he's
the main character right alongside
batman sharing possibly equal screen
time jeffrey wright is such a great
person for this role too by the way he's
got that real hard edge about him much
like the year one comic showing off how
someone so good can handle himself in a
department so crooked he helps ground
batman while from a filmmaking
standpoint simultaneously serves to
showcase batman's genius they share
crime scenes together tackling clues and
riddles and where gordon and the other
police officers struggle batman's there
to piece things together in an instant
their body cop antics are also a huge
source of comedy in this film despite
how dark this film can be and often is
it also manages to feel appropriately
funny without jarring against the
overall tone the thumb drive gag the
pull your punch gag the classic
disappearing act they have such awesome
chemistry together a chemistry i don't
think has ever been committed to the
screen so convincingly and with that
said i think the only real place that
this film falters is in its choice of
finale as i mentioned earlier this film
is a slow burn detective thriller for
about two and a half hours of its run
time its action is fairly minimal with
an emphasis on the cerebral aspects of
each character it barely feels like a
superhero film and yet when the
riddler's plan is blown open it
immediately transitions into a city-wide
level threat it's a huge scale event on
par with the dark knight rises final act
that feels a little at odds with how
low-key the film has been prior to this
point i think by and large though this
is a small complaint while it is a large
event it's not a snyder level
punch-a-thon special effects
extravaganza the way the film focuses
itself is concentrated enough that it
comes across more like a slice of a
disaster movie more so than anything
else and what it does thematically is
what's most important after all the fact
is batman may have won in the sense that
he's learned what he needs to to be a
symbol for gotham but loses the conflict
in this film he didn't catch the riddler
he let himself be caught he solved the
riddles too late gotham city is left
completely destroyed parts are cut off
people are left desperate and isolated
it's like the setup for the comic no
man's land and that's hugely exciting
for the future of this franchise if
reeves continues at the helm and that's
where my excitement comes from here for
the future the future of this franchise
has me incredibly excited off the back
of this wonderful film there are a huge
number of hints towards future content
throughout and i can't wait to see how
they play out i've not even mentioned
colin farrell's penguin despite the fact
that it's one of the most stand out
performances in this film and some of
the best transformative acting in recent
memory the fact he's getting his own hbo
spin-off series that focuses harder on
the corrupt aspects of gotham's police
system is so exciting then of course
there's also the part where batman
injects himself with this green fluid
was it just adrenaline was it venom
hinting at bane or the addiction story
from the comics of the same name heck
there's even what appears to be a joker
cameo at one point this film is just
packed full of detail i cannot emphasize
enough just how much i adore it i do
genuinely think this may very well be my
favorite batman film to date now that
may be recency bias talking but the way
it brings the source material to the big
screen is just so uncompromising and
perfectly accurate and with such a
compelling story and awesome
performances to boot i can just barely
fault it if i had to put a score in it i
would probably go with a 9 out of 10 a
strong 9 out of 10. i think also because
of this it means retroactively it
affects some of the scores that came
before most critically sending halle
berry's catwoman into the negatives
justice in conclusion it is my firm
belief that all-time comic fans will
love this incredible three-hour
spectacular that doesn't feel at all
like three hours as always subscribe for
more reviews like this and i'll see you
all next time thanks for watching
[Music]
you